let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay number one black lives matter
agitators have returned to the familiar
well uh harassing random white people
while they eat dinner this is the
this is the you know one of the one of
the primary tactics now of blm
and because blm are very tough and brave
they focus once again
on elderly people watch
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
so tough really tough intimidating two
elderly people you know
big big tough guys they're so strong and
brave are these warriors for freedom
oh and by the way um here's blm same day
same city
harassing and assaulting a black
mcdonald's manager
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
wow okay well so apparently every time
i've seen
you know someone shout at a mcdonald's
manager because they got a six-piece
nugget instead of an eight-piece nugget
uh that was really they were really
advancing racial justice and i didn't
realize that so when you shout out to
mcdonald's manager
you're advancing racial justice you know
we hear the word hateful
tossed around quite a bit uh the left
especially likes to call
everything hateful really and most of
the time hateful
really means something more like uh
has opinions that differ from my own or
is more passionate about this issue than
i am that's most of the time when
someone calls something hateful that's
really what they mean
but um what we see here
with blm this is actually finally
a a real hateful movement movement
hateful in the most literal sense they
are filled with hate
they have only hate to offer um
they aren't trying to achieve anything
positive it's not like this is just a
misguided way
of achieving some positive goal no there
is no positive goal
there's nothing harassing and
intimidating old people while they eat
dinner you know that's
that's not something you do because you
have a goal in mind
it's something you do because you hate
you hate them for the race you hate them
for their age you hate them for their
assumed socioeconomic status blm is only
hate
it is defined by hate it hates white
people it hates police it hates
conservatives
i mean he hates pretty much everything
and everyone that doesn't bend to its
whims
uh it hates black people too i mean if
if you've
noticed in that in that last video we
played as a black
mcdonald's manager um racial minority
middle class
you know as far as we know not a
conservative or trump supporter
but they hated him too why well because
he didn't dance to their tune that's it
you have to do exactly what blm wants
and if you don't then they hate you
and you're an enemy and uh you're a
fascist and you're hitler and
they can do whatever they want to you
and they're morally justified in doing
so that's the attitude
okay number two um but wait blm maybe is
not so bad after all report from the
hill reading now says
despite several incidents of protests
against racism and police brutality
turning violent
more than 90 percent of the summer's
protests were peaceful according to an
analysis released thursday
the report produced by the non-profit
armed conflict location and event data
project
identified 7750 protests between may 26
and august
22nd in 2400 locations the report found
that about 220
became violent a term described defined
as demonstrators fighting with police or
with counter protesters
the term also applies to demonstrators
or demonstrations that resulted in
property damage
in 93 of cases analyzed there was no
violence
okay so a few problems here first of all
um there's no reason to trust these
numbers at all period so we could just
end it there i guess
second based on this definition what we
just saw there
blmrs walking around harassing and
intimidating the elderly
that doesn't count as violent by by this
definition
now it is it is violent but it doesn't
count
by this tally to be violent by this
definition you have to assault a police
officer or burn something
or you know maybe kill a you know a
random pedestrian as has happened
maybe that will count i'm not sure the
third thing though is um
even even putting all that aside let's
pretend that the actual
figure is seven percent seven percent is
a lot
okay that's a lot 220 violent riots
that even the media will call violent in
one summer
220 and you're we're supposed to be
impressed with that oh it was only 220.
only 220 violent riots in a summer
that's it no that's that's a lot
uh i i am not impressed with blm's
restraint even if i pretended that it
was
only seven percent i mean the crazy
thing is
march for life pro-lifers get together
hundreds of thousands been doing this
uh every year for for over four decades
it's never been violent there has there
has been zero percent violence
over four decades with hundreds of
thousands of people
gathered together now that's impressive
okay
that is an impressive streak but when
you can't even put together
you know like four days in a row of
non-violent protests
um no that's you know what that tells me
that tells me this is a violent movement
that's what it tells me by definition
seven percent of your protest your
quote-unquote protest turn violent
that's a violent movement to be
non-violent that number needs to be
zero percent 0.001 percent maybe
um okay let's see number three now i
don't know where this is from
or the context but this apparently is a
well it's a vegan funeral
for slabs of meat at the supermarket i
don't know when
it happened but it's making the rounds
online pretty heart-wrenching stuff
let's let's take a look
[Music]
yeah it's that's that's emotional
um and i join these vegans in many ways
i
i am with them and i too hope that one
day the sight
of a murdered cow will be rare um
because that tastes a lot better than
medium well
and actually this is a common vegan
tactic it turns out i looked it up and
um
they do this a lot i guess i've never
had the pleasure of witnessing it in
person
when i'm at the supermarket i wish i
would but i've never seen it but here's
some more footage i found
this from an animal rights youtube
channel and uh in this case they are
mourning and commemorating some frozen
chickens watch
[Music]
go
[Music]
may they rest in peace is pieces
with gravy uh as for the the vegans
themselves well you know they say that
there's a mental health crisis in
america and
exhibit a right there number four the
united nations sent out a tweet
yesterday it said
the covet 19 pandemic is demonstrating
what we all know
millennia of patriarchy have resulted in
a male-dominated world with a
male-dominated culture
which damages everyone women men girls
and boys
it's demonstrating what now
how does the what what does the
patriarchy have to do with
i mean okay i i guess like this is kind
of how
i remember thinking back in 2008
how the global financial crisis really
demonstrated the need for
more trans representation in the
australian
avant-garde theater scene which is to
say the two things aren't connected at
all
but i suppose i mean really any dif any
event can demonstrate any point you want
if you're not worried about things like
making sense
uh number five finally for our most
important story of the day and uh look i
say this in all seriousness i've i've of
course never
been a supporter of joe biden i never
saw myself you know
voting for him i still probably won't
but um i don't know he just made a case
for himself
that even i can't ignore he
he he made one point that sort of made
me pause and say hmm
maybe there is a case for voting for him
i don't know he was being interviewed by
reporters yesterday
and uh and this is this is something
that he mentioned kind of a sales pitch
for himself that i thought was pretty
persuasive listen
step or two uh what's your response to
that look at how he steps and look how i
step
watch how i run up ramps and he stumbles
down ramps
okay come on yeah that's a good point i
mean
if you like me have always planned to
vote for whoever can most skillfully
and swiftly navigate a ramp
then biden might be our guy i'm a one
issue voter
okay and my issue is ramps
i want to know how fast can you walk
down them how confidently
how gracefully think of all the pres
of all the ramps that a president walks
down in a i think the latest study was a
president has to walk down a ramp
14 times a week okay so that's a lot of
ramps
and i mean do you want a guy who's
tripping and stumbling down the ramp
or do you want someone who could do a
cartwheel down the ramp if you wanted to
i just wish that i was alive back in the
19th century uh to see grover cleveland
uh because that man was a master of
ramps he used to he used to
go down ramps on his hands doing
handstands one of the all-time greats
when it comes to to ramps um
anyway interesting stuff there the ramp
debate rages on
but a little bit of food for thought
something to think about
with with the rams i'm glad that biden
brought that up well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content